vous reconnaissez peut-être la maison
red patte sur la rue du musée
donc c'est tout près de l'autre histoire
ça fait des décennies que des groupes
essaient de sauver la maison redpath de
toutes sortes de projets souvent
montréal voulait également la sauve et
or elle sera démolie
elle sera peut-être démoli dès demain
matin comme nous dit à nourrice despatie
les arbres ont commencé à être coupée
sur le terrain où s'élève la maison
votre pâte depuis 1886 c'est pour faire
de la place en vue de construire un
large bâtiment qui doit contenir autour
de 80 chambres pour étudiants au niveau
2 pour dinu bumbaru d'héritage montréal
le fait que le propriétaire est obtenu
les permis de démolition et de
construction juste avant noël est un
affront qu'est ce qui va se passer
les promoteurs mettre la main sur
certaines des autres grandes maisons
dans le quartier l'arrondissement de
ville-marie ces règles d'urbanisme ça
nous livre pas de la qualité ça nous
livre des blocs comme ça rien du charme
de cette maison de style queen anne
située juste au nord du musée des
beaux-arts ne sera conservée depuis les
années 80 les défenseurs du patrimoine
ont demandé à ce que cette maison soit
protégé aujourd'hui l'on récompense de
nombreuses années de négligence on peut
dans un câble super message extrêmement
préoccupée a envoyé
surtout dans le cas d'une nouvelle
administration qui veut montrer qu'elle
change les choses
l'arrondissement ville-marie a émis le
permis de construction parce que le
projet respecte les normes nous dit on
il y aurait pu par exemple exigé que
death partie de ceux de ce magnifique
bâtiment sont intégrés à la nouvelle
construction
alors je pense qu'il y avait des options
à examiner la maison redpath sera donc
démoli à moins que sauvons montréal
obtiennent une injonction
c'était en 1986 28 ans plus tard il ne
semble plus y avoir d'obstacle à sa
démolition ici anne louise despatie
radio canada montréal